veamos si podemos escribir 1.501 como un
porcentaje lo que realmente queremos
hacer es escribir esta cantidad como
algo entre siento lo que hacemos es
escribir esta cantidad como 1.500 1
sobre 1 no hemos alterado su valor esto
lo multiplicamos por 100 sobre 100 y
tampoco modificamos la expresión pues
100 sobre 100 es igual a 1 y esto nos va
a dar igual a multiplicamos el
denominador y esto va a ser 1%
multiplicando estos dos términos 1 por
100 es igual a 100 y si multiplicamos el
numerador tenemos que es 1.500 1%
recordemos que al multiplicar por 10
movemos el punto decimal un lugar a la
derecha volvemos a multiplicar por 10
nuevamente movemos el punto decimal un
lugar a la derecha estamos multiplicando
por 10 dos veces o multiplicando por 100
esto es multiplicar por 10 y esto es
multiplicar por 100 entonces aquí es
donde va a quedar el punto decimal vamos
a tener 150
no estamos reescribiendo entonces 1.501
como 150.1 sobre 100 o 150 punto 1%
dejame escribir esto 150.1 x
bien puesto lo podemos escribir como
150.1 por ciento pues sería 150 punto 1
por ciento lo que es igual a 150 punto
uno por ciento usando el símbolo que
conocemos hemos concluido esencialmente
para simplificar el proceso lo que hemos
hecho es multiplicar este número por 100
para obtener 150 punto uno y eso es un
porcentaje hay que asegurarse de poner
ese símbolo de porcentaje